bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir et
metteur en scène dramaturge écrivain
traducteur essayiste et j'en passe
bonsoir Gérald de garretti je suis ravie
de vous accueillir dans cette émission
vous publiez un magnifique pour les arts
de la parole chez Acte Sud il faut voir
comment se parle c'est le titre mal trop
mal déplorez-vous tout le monde
s'exprime et personne ne s'écoutait bien
on va vous écouter le mieux possible ce
soir on a du temps on est ensemble
pendant une heure pour décrypter
l'actualité de ce mardi 31 janvier et
l'actualité ce soir elle s'est jouée
dans la rue deuxième mobilisation
deuxième démonstration de force contre
la réforme des retraites et deuxième
manche à nouveau remporté par les
syndicats on va faire le point sur les
chiffres et sur la bataille qui se joue
aussi à l'Assemblée nationale sur quoi
le gouvernement pourrait-il bouger les
lignes sur cette réforme et bien c'est
notre débat ce soir dans un instant avec
nos invités
juste avant de retrouver bien sûr aux
alentours de 20h15 les partis près de
nos affranchis et puis Bourbon Express
votre rendez-vous quotidien désormais
avec Elsa mont d'un gamin l'histoire de
jour à l'Assemblée voilà pour le menu ce
soir Gérald garuti vous me suivez ça
vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
encore plus de monde Paris réussi donc
pour les syndicats la mobilisation à
réuni plus que le 19 janvier derrière
dans les grandes villes et au-delà plus
de manifestants mais un peu moins de
grévistes on le verra comment la
majorité va réagir quel bilan tiré de
cette deuxième manche y a-t-il des
marges de manœuvre à l'Assemblée
nationale je vais vous la poser tout à
l'heure cette question c'est sûr Louis
Marguerite bonsoir bonsoir et merci
d'être là vous êtes député renaissance
de Saône-et-Loire en face de vous Adrien
Clouet bonsoir bonsoir ravi de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau député la
France insoumise de Haute-Garonne dans
les cortèges parisiens cet après-midi
bonsoir Jean-Marc Daniel bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes économiste
professeur émérite à l'ESCP enfin
bonsoir Fabienne tatto bonsoir bienvenue
à vous vous représenter la CGT dont vous
êtes la secrétaire nationale pour les
ingénieurs les cadres et les techniciens
Gérald garretti vous qui plaidez pour un
débat
apaisé serein que le débat redevienne un
art et bien je vous propose de nous dire
si on y arrive ce soir ou si on est
condamné sur les retraites un dialogue
de sourd voilà je vous donne la parole
dans un instant on a besoin de faire des
points le point sur les chiffres qui
étaient dans les cortèges ce soir
j'appelle mon camarade Stéphane lakowski
200 secondes pour relever des fils et le
chrono de la côte tout de suite
et on se retrouve
pour vous accueillir
bonsoir Myriam bonsoir toutes à tous
bonsoir Stéphane alors plus de monde que
le 19 manifestement donc j'ai un goût
pour la métaphore sportive là je sens
qu'on est sur un combat autour de la
réforme des retraites à ma gauche
l'Union syndicale qui trouve que c'est
injuste à ma droite le gouvernement qui
trouve que c'est indispensable donc la
première manche on s'en souvient était
emporté haut la main on peut féliciter
l'interfe syndical représenter ici par
la CGT plus d'un million même plus de 2
millions de CGT la deuxième manche bah
vous l'avez dit pareil encore une
victoire pour un syndicat encore plus
importante on n'a pas le chiffre
officiel mais la CGT dit plus de 2
millions 8 de manifeste pendant les
premiers chiffres on a pu constater
c'était ce matin aux manifeste d'abord
dans les villes de province avant de la
manifester à Paris je vous montre
quelques chiffres donc on voit déjà
qu'il y a des villes qui ont des coins
de France on se met mobilise plus La
Roche-sur-Yon c'est 50 000 habitants il
y a plus de manifestants qu'à Reims où
il y a 150 000 ou 180 000 habitants donc
ça c'est les répartitions pour le
territoire mais on voit surtout que
entre le 19 et le 31 dans toutes ces
villes et bien ça ce sont les chiffres
de la préfecture de la mobilisation est
plus importante pareil à Marseille la
grande métropole on s'amuse toujours des
grosses différences de chiffres entre le
comptage de la préfecture et celui de la
CGT à Marseille vous voyez que les
cadres il est très important mais CGT et
préfecture sont d'accord sur une chose
pour dire que le nombre de manifestants
a augmenté ce qui fait que le match on
était même pas arrivé à la fin de la
journée on était même pas la mi-temps du
match ce midi Laurent Berger pouvait
déjà se sentir dans la peau du vainqueur
on l'écoute on mobilise pas un million
cinq deux millions de personnes en
allant juste chercher l'écume des
militants c'est syndicaux c'est beaucoup
plus large beaucoup plus profond et donc
je crois que c'est pour le gouvernement
un vrai signal que les 64 ans sont
refusés
donc sur vous devez mettre un petit
bémol à cette victoire de tenter
d'équilibrer un peu le tableau dire ah
oui mais regardez les taux de grévistes
ont un peu baissé donc c'est notamment
vrai dans la fonction publique assez
nettement même à EDF qui est quand même
faire de lance la lutte contre la
réforme fait un peu baisser je te dis ça
n'a pas atteint la mobilisation ça va
dans son doute dire que ceux qui avaient
fait grève en se mobiliser bien on s'est
remplacé par d'autres peut-être déjà
notamment qu'on a plus vu dans les
cortèges aujourd'hui qui n'était pas
très présent auparavant alors
gouvernement là il est dans les cordes
forcément il encaisse mais il a cet
argument en disant enfin je comprends
pas pourquoi vous fâchez on l'avait
promise les trois formes des retraites
le candidat Macron l'avait dit ah oui
c'est vrai mais Philippe donc Martinez
de bonne humeur aujourd'hui donc un peu
taquin il dit oui il avait promis mais
il avait promis autre chose aussi on
l'écoute
lui qui avait dit j'ai changé il faut
que j'écoute
il devrait je pense encore aujourd'hui
entendre que il y a du monde qui est pas
content bref comment le gouvernement va
s'en sortir là pour l'instant je vois
pas trop on pourrait compter évidemment
en cas de durcissement sur une division
entre CFDT CGT CGT étant trop dur pour
la CBT bon pour l'instant c'est pas le
cas regarder pas la peine de faire des
plans sur les planètes qui sont là ils
se tiennent bras dessus bras dessous il
s'amuse un peu pareil à gauche il y a eu
pas mal de disputes pour des raisons
diverses et variées à gauche oh mais ils
sont tous réunis donc voilà ça aussi
cette vertu enfin je dis tous non pas
tous il en manquent il était où le
patron il était à Marseille on écoute
Mélenchon monsieur Macron est certain de
perdre tout ce qu'il est en train de
faire c'est de nous faire perdre du
temps à tous de l'énergie et de l'argent
donc ça il est certain de perdre aucun
doute pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon en même
temps c'est pas trop son truc de douter
alors pour que le débat est un peu
d'intérêt je vous laisse quand même
regarder ce chiffre certes 70% des
Français sont contre la réforme mais en
revanche il y en a aussi
77%. je pense que malgré tout c'est très
fort va finir par être voté donc la
résignation n'est pas loin la victoire
n'est pas acquise bah le débat est
ouvert en même temps merci beaucoup
Stéphane donc 2,8 millions pour la CGT
un million 200000 de chez bien de tomber
pour le ministère de l'intérieur c'est
donc déjà plus quel que soit les sources
que le 19 janvier Louis Marguerite
quelle leçon politique vous tirez ce
soir de cette deuxième épreuve de force
contre vous non mais il faut constater
qu'il y a effectivement une mobilisation
qui est forte forcément un peu plus
élevée que que la fois d'avant c'était
le cas d'ailleurs aussi dans ma
circonscription à peu près les mêmes
chiffres d'ailleurs je suis en dessous
des Montceau-les-Mines il faut
évidemment être à l'écoute regardez ce
qu'on peut améliorer dans ce texte il y
a déjà eu des évolutions je le rappelle
j'imagine qu'on rentrera pas dans le
détail mais de du texte entre les
premières discussions qui ont eu lieu au
mois de septembre dernier au mois
d'octobre et et l'arrivée la bataille à
l'Assemblée on verra ça tout à l'heure
évidemment il faut faire des ajustements
qui sont nécessaires sur la pénibilité
sur les carrières longues etc et ça
évidemment il faut qu'on y soit au vert
c'est clair mais en revanche enfin on
fait pas une réforme difficile
évidemment on sent bien quand on est
député de la majorité qu'on défend un
texte comme ça une grosse journée de
manifestation nationale qui est encore
plus douté
et d'ailleurs non seulement il faut être
à l'écoute de ceux qui ont manifesté
mais également de ceux qui n'ont pas pu
manifester parce que soit ils avaient
pas de moyenne locomotion soit parce que
ils peuvent te permettre peut-être le
seul point d’accord que j'ai accueilli
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ça fait aussi perdre
de l'argent mais ce que je veux juste te
dire c'est que c'est la forme évidemment
difficile mais en revanche et c'est ce
qu'on dit les ministres c'est ce qu'a
dit la rappeler la première ministre on
n'échappa une mesure qui augmente un peu
qui augmente la durée de cotisation et
en tout cas en tout cas qui augmente non
mais on entend le changement de voilà de
langage on appelle ça les éléments de
langage il y a un effort nécessaire on
va on va y venir parce que très
clairement le gouvernement a durcit le
temps depuis quelques jours Adrien cloué
vous vous y étiez on a le sentiment
quand même que c'était très bon enfant
la première fois là ce qui a plus de
colère est-ce que vous sentez que les
gens ont envie d'en découdre en fin de
manif attention à Paris 18 personnes
interpellées c'est c'est une voilà c'est
un fait l'ambiance était aussi assez
familiale il y avait des gens avec les
poussettes donc c'est sont les meilleurs
manifestations possibles et c'est
d'ailleurs parce que il y a ce cadre là
qui permet d'y aller de manière joyeuse
en famille avec les amis les voisins que
on a appris de 3 millions de personnes
qui manifestent on est quand même à peu
près 20000 manifestants par députés
macronistes on a quand même un nombre de
personnes très important
on n'est pas à ça près mais on constate
évidemment une forme de fébrilité assez
forte dans la macronie alors fébrilité
qui se révèle lorsque il parle parce que
par exemple meilleur VRP c'est Franck
Rister à chaque fois qu'il parle il met
un million de gens dans la rue en plus
donc c'est formidable et d'autre part
plus pénalisante pour les pour les
femmes je précise était injuste et que
les femmes payées et par ailleurs on se
rend bien compte que les gens qui
marchent aujourd'hui ne viennent pas
pour demander des ajustements ils
viennent pas pour discuter une lettre ou
une phrase ou des tours d'un article du
texte ils viennent pour demander le
retrait de la loi bien compris ce qui se
joue c'est l'allongement des trimestres
donc la baisse des pensions pour ceux
qui vont pas tenir et c'est le report de
l'âge de départ à la retraite donc des
milliers de personnes qui décéderont
avant de pouvoir toucher leur retraite
en dépit d'une vie de travail parfum de
95 Fabienne dato j'ai regardé au tout
début des mobilisations des grandes
grèves de 95 c'était moins de de
personnes dans la rue ce qui frappe
c'est la province c'est vrai que ça
mobilise beaucoup des petites villes
notamment le trafic c'est très très
perturbé ça on l'a vu vous diriez que
quoi c'est un mouvement qui va durer
parce qu'il est contraint dans le temps
il y a l'assemblée qui le temps à
l'Assemblée tourne en même temps d'abord
nous on est très satisfait du
beaucoup de mobilisation et on s'y
attendait
dans nos contacts qu'on a dans nos
hautboises dans les assemblées générales
qu'on fait on voyait que les salariés
étaient très motivés et avec prix aussi
ce qui les attendait avec cette retraite
donc on n'est pas surpris en fait du
chiffre de mobilisation on en est très
très heureux effectivement il faut quand
même noter que dans les villes de
province on a des taux de de grévistes
et de manifestations qui est vraiment
très élevée c'est quand même
significatif il y a moins de grévistes
ça coûte cher de faire la grève moi je
pense que c'est un signe d'intelligence
des salariés qui ont compris que ce
mouvement il allait sans doute s'étaler
sur une certaine durée et donc on se
prépare aussi à ça on a déjà ça en tête
pourquoi parce qu'on sait que le
gouvernement il va pas lâcher l'affaire
comme ça puisque Macron notre président
dit être élu avoir été élu pour faire
cette réforme ce qui est totalement faux
il n'a pas la légitimité de nous imposer
cette réforme et c'est un premier tour
voilà c'est donc
non on est vraiment très satisfait de
cette manifestation qui a la
caractéristique de mettre dans la rue
des personnes avec des profils très
différents des jeunes
donc c'est vraiment une belle réussite
je vous propose de regarder la
composition des cortèges et je vous
donne la parole juste après Jean-Marc
Daniel salarié du public enseignant
soignant mais aussi du privé sans
compter les jeunes jusqu'où les antis 64
ans sont-ils prêts à tenir c'est un sur
le terrain signé Clément Pergaud
[Musique]
ce n'est que la deuxième grande journée
de mobilisation mais la lutte contre la
réforme des retraites a déjà des allures
de course de fond dans les cortèges les
manifestants insistent pour montrer leur
détermination sans faille dans le bras
de fer engagé avec le gouvernement hors
de question de la chez les premiers
on continuera autant qu'il faudra on va
pas laisser passer une saloperie pour
nous pour les enfants et pour tout le
monde nous irons jusqu'au bout je ne
sais pas où mais en tout cas on ira très
très loin la bataille sera long et on va
gagner on va gagner on va gagner on est
déterminé on va gagner alors oui ça va
probablement s'installer dans la durée
mais pas de la faute de manifestants de
la faute des réponses
une admissible du gouvernement c'est pas
négociable c'est pas négociable on verra
quand il y aura 5 millions de personnes
dans la rue si ça sera pas négociable
au-delà des intentions il y a la réalité
des possibles journée de grève à
répétition les manifestants s'organisent
déjà pour tenir dans la durée qu'il soit
dans le public ou dans le privé
indépendant ou enseignant à chacun sa
méthode et parfois c'est sacrifices
entre journée de congés et jours de
grève pour pouvoir à la fin du mois
tenir que ça se ressente pas trop trop
bah après il faudra bien que je mangeais
un moment ça c'est clair ça coûte cher
mais en tout cas oui c'est un sacrifice
j'ai choisi d'éliminer les vacances et
de pouvoir venir dire qu'on n'est pas
d'accord je suis chercheur et donc du
coup j'ai la chance de pouvoir avoir un
bon salaire donc je peux faire grève
plusieurs fois la licence dans laquelle
je suis les profs sont tous très engagés
donc ils sont tous ils seront tous très
compréhensifs au niveau des absences moi
je serai là tant que je pourrais des
manifestants déterminés un gouvernement
inflexible le rapport de force semble se
figer et la guerre d'usure s'installer
Jean-Marc Daniel vous êtes économiste on
va parler du fond de la réforme et vous
avez aussi une certaine expérience
d'observateur du pays c'est pas facile
d'accepter une réforme des retraites
jamais ce front du refus on voit qu'il
est il existe aussi bien dans le privé
que dans le public ne vous surprend pas
oui et non c'est à dire que tout le
monde se souvient de la célèbre formule
de Michel Rocca quand il a lancé le
livre blanc sur les retraites il avait
dit il y a de quoi faire sauter tous les
gouvernements qui s'attaqueront à ce à
ce dossier et donc la plupart des
gouvernements aussi de dire bon on va
commencer par faire de la pédagogie donc
le gouvernement Jospin par exemple avait
demandé à Jean-Michel Charpin qui était
le commissaire aux plantes faire un
rapport et si elle est intéressante
c'est que le le rapport TV était signé à
l'époque par les syndicats indiquait
bien que de toute façon compte tenu de
l'évolution démographique il faudrait
adapter en permanence l'âge de départ à
la retraite à la réalité du pays et donc
on rentre de nouveau dans une phase de
d'action avec toujours le même pilier on
commence par faire de la pédagogie et
ensuite on agit sauf que je trouve que
la pédagogie est très faites chaque fois
que les gouvernements parlent on a parlé
de Monsieur Rister c'est au contraire ça
détruit les arguments ces derniers
cette bataille de la pédagogie et de la
communication à définir la réalité des
enjeux et de ce qu'il y a derrière quand
le président de la République présente
ses vœux il dit le véritable problème
c'est que le pays ne travaille pas assez
et ça quand on regarde il y a encore un
rapport du FMI qui est sorti là sur la
situation de l'économie mondiale le
chapitre qui est consacré à la France
indique bien que le problème de la
France c'est que elle ne travaille pas
assez dans quelle vie au-dessus de ses
moyens elle accumule des déficits
intérieurs et extérieurs et ça va
devenir assez vite insoutenable bon ce
discours qui était celui du 31 décembre
n'est plus du tout celui qu'on a tenu
par la suite ensuite on nous a expliqué
que la réforme allait permettre
d'équilibrer le système de retraite mais
là certains de gens dit mais en réalité
quand vous regardez l'évolution des
déficits c'est pas si dramatique que ça
donc changement de pied au lieu de dire
mais le déficit en réalité il est plus
ou moins artificiel on peut basculer
certaines recettes d'un côté ou de
l'autre qualité le véritable enjeu c'est
le déficit global du secteur public et
pas tellement celui qui est concentré
sur le régime de retraite ce discours
est abandonné discours le système est
injuste il y a un ministre vous l'avez
rappelé qui dit oui mais c'est vrai la
réforme est injuste donc vous avez une
communication qui est une communication
qui est au-delà de la maladresse qui est
dans une forme d'amateurisme qui est
assez surprenant dernier remarque sur
les mouvements qui ont eu lieu en 1995
moi ce qui m'avait frappé on en parlait
c'est que c'était concentré sur quelques
entreprises mais ces entreprises c'est
vraiment en grève Paris était bloqué
aujourd'hui la RATP le réseau de bus
fonctionnait pratiquement et quand vous
regardez dans les grandes villes de
province que ce soit Lyon Bordeaux ou
Toulouse les les les le système de
transport n'était pas bloqué et donc il
y a une sorte de
d'expectative une partie de la
population attend et les lieux
traditionnels du du combat syndical sont
en train plus ou moins de se retirer du
certaines façons on a vu beaucoup de
lycéens beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup mais
la force militante pas forcément au
rendez-vous
est-ce que vous reconnaissez l'avoir
perdu cette bataille de la communication
de l'explication comme le dit et le
démontre assez bien Jean-Marc Daniel non
mais il y a beaucoup de choses sur
lequel il faut que je puisse sur cette
question que je vous adresse évidemment
c'est pas simple sur une réforme sur
lequel il est demandé des efforts un
certain nombre de Français en effet donc
je crois pas qu'on est perdu à
communication sur la sur le sol sur sur
les ministres c'est un mauvais c'est un
mauvais procès qu'on fait à Franck
ricter comme ado d'ailleurs parce que
évidemment on va pas résoudre la
question de l'égalité salariale des
hommes et des femmes sur cette réforme
là en revanche en revanche pardon
bien parce qu'on l'Empire pas puisque
non n'empire pas et il y a eu il y a eu
sur une je vais vous expliquer sur une
mauvaise phrase qui a été mal interprété
et bien en fait
cette réforme qu'on soit bien au clair
c'est un économiste voilà pour c'est
intéressant que ça vienne de lui cette
parole comment vous l'accueillez je
pense que dans une réforme qui est par
définition compliquée parce jusqu'à
présent qu'est-ce qu'on a fait au
Parlement on a voté des réformes qui
étaient qui étaient plutôt dépensières
et après on pouvait toujours on pouvait
toujours dire que c'était trop pas assez
qu'il fallait pas accès sur tel ou telle
politique même la loi de programmation
du ministère d'intérieur c'est noir en
réalité on va mettre plus de moyens et
on a raison de le faire là on a une
réforme qui est effectivement vise à et
ce sera pas la seule augmenter la
quantité de travail pour tenir notre
modèle social donc c'est évidemment
c'est difficile à expliquer donc donc on
prend effectivement tous les points on
met c'est on essaie de mettre en valeur
aussi ce qui a été discuté avec les
syndicats donc un certain nombre la CFDT
l'une ça reconnaisse qu'il y a eu des
efforts sur ces points le compte
professionnel pénibilité on pourra y
revenir et un certain nombre on va
rentrer dans le détail donc évidemment
que ce soit pas simple je suis bien
entendre mais en revanche on veut pas
dire qu'il y a pas eu de il y a pas eu
des effets
on entend c'est peut-être pas facile
pour les Français mais c'est pas évident
donc c'est pour le gouvernement et on
l'entend Fabienne tatto la terre
cervicale vient de tomber il y a deux
dates mardi 7 février ça c'est le
lendemain du débat à l'Assemblée
nationale qui commence dans les muscles
6 février et le samedi 11 février ça
c'est un week-end c'est plus étonnant
peut-être que c'est pour préserver
justement
le coût le coup de la grève ça c'est
quoi c'est un compromis cfdtcgt
c'est aussi une inspiration d'une partie
de la population on a un faut pas
oublier que le pouvoir d'achat des
Français a largement baissé parce que
des salaires n'augmentent pas les
entreprises sont financées pour nous
proposer des bas salaires toute la
politique de financement des bases en
paix que les salaires sont irrés vers le
bas les négociations n'ont pas permis
des augmentations de salaires qui
répondent à l'inflation qu'on connaît
donc il est normal aussi que on ait des
on a l'impression qu'on est plutôt sur
voilà un mouvement plutôt CFDT
c'est-à-dire on essaie de garder
l'opinion parce que le blocage du pays
ça fait souvent perdre l'opinion moi je
crois qu'en fait
je crois que l'interdicale elle répond
avec intelligence aux préoccupations des
salariés et à leur conclusion actuelle
le fait de proposer deux dates je trouve
que c'est assez démonstratif et que ça
va permettre de répondre à différents
aux différents besoins et conditions de
montrer le désaccord profond qu'il y a
avec cette réforme
parlera de ce que c'est que un art du
débat tout à l'heure avec vous Gérald
garretti bon on a compris il y aura pas
de recul sur le recul de l'âge à 64 ans
Olivier du soft le ministre du Travail
en boîte le pas de la première ministre
c'est la mesure phare elle est non
négociable la réforme est devenue je
cite nécessaire écouter le ministre
si nous retirons cette réforme
le système serait déficitaire il
s'écroulerait et la pension le niveau
moyen de revenus au niveau de moyens des
pensions des retraités baisseraient de
20% comme c'est indiqué dans le conseil
d'orientation du corps bonsoir Stéphanie
Despierre et merci d'avoir patienté
depuis la salle des quatre colonnes en
duplex avec nous le gouvernement
clairement a durci le ton c'est
manifeste
oui fini la pédagogie le gouvernement
affiche un ton inflexible dimanche c'est
Manuel c'est Elisabeth borde pardon qui
a déclaré que les 64 ans ne sont plus
négociables l'indice Emmanuel Macron qui
poursuit la réforme est désormais
indispensable pour sauver notre système
et dans la foulée tous les dirigeants du
parti et du groupe Renaissance sont sur
le même temps alors le camp présidentiel
a d'abord voulu convaincre du bien-fondé
de sa réforme à parler de justice
sociale mais aujourd'hui ministre et
député ont compris qu'ils avaient perdu
la bataille de l'opinion d'où ce
changement de stratégie en parallèle ils
accentuent la pression pour s'assurer
qu'aucune voie ne fera défaut au sein de
la majorité et de ses alliés ici à
l'Assemblée la Réunion tout à l'heure
entre les trois groupes et la première
ministre en tout début d'après-midi
devait servir à resserrer les roues à
mobiliser les troupes Elisabeth borne la
martelée on se bat pour sauver le
système par répartition on se bat pour
notre modèle social je ne doute pas une
seconde que la majorité sera unie sauf
que vous l'avez vu les premiers
frondeurs sont apparus la semaine
dernière et que l'ambiance n'était pas
très bonne tout à l'heure ça a été même
houleux entre certains députés les
renaissances réclamant un peu plus de
solidarité de la part de leurs
homologues d'horizon et du MoDem dans le
viseur surtout Richard Ramos député du
MoDem qui hier soir sur un plateau télé
à parler d'une réforme injuste et bien
les députés Renaissance non pas apprécié
ils l'ont dit tout à l'heure et c'est
deux députés modems qui eux n'ont pas
apprécié cette leçon donnée alors que la
Richard rameau s'ils sont même partis en
claquant la porte de la Réunion alors ça
c'est pour la coulisse Stéphanie sur le
fond que peut-on attendre de ce débat
parlementaire est-ce qu'il y a du gras à
moudre est-ce qu'on peut encore négocier
cette réforme dans la discussion entre
député
et bien il ne faut pas en attendre grand
chose Myriam car s'il y a des bougies
comme on appelle cela en langage
macroniste des changements quoi et bien
ce sera à clairement à la marche sur
l'index seniors peut-être avec
d'éventuelles sanctions financières ou
un élargissement à des entreprises de
taille moyenne peut être aussi quelques
modifications mineures sur les
trimestres à qui par les femmes pour
l'éducation à des enfants mais rien qui
ne changera la physionomie à de la
réforme le gouvernement ne veut plus
toucher à son projet de loi les
républicains eux pourtant n'ont pas
renoncé ils veulent que la durée de
cotisation l'emporte sur l'âge légal
pour ceux qui ont commencé à travailler
avant 21 ans sauf que leur amendement
n'a même pas été discuté en commission
il a été jugé irrecevable colère donc de
la droite qui malgré les négociations de
ces dernières semaines mais à nouveau la
pression sur l'exécutif et une partie
des républicains menace clairement pas
de mesures sur les carrières longues
c'est à dire pas de vote de la réforme
la commission vous le savez travaille
sur cette réforme des retraites jusqu'à
demain soir et puis les choses plus
sérieuses commenceront dit avec le débat
dans l'hémicycle si beaucoup Stéphanie
Despierre Elisabeth borne ce soir qui
dit je cite qu'elle entend les doutes et
les interrogations Louis Marguerite
est-ce qu'il y a des choses à négocier
dans ce débat parlementaire ou est-ce
que comme on commence à le comprendre le
gouvernement sert les rentes très
durement d'abord je rappelle aussi parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de choses sur vous
n'avez pas la légitimité pour proposer
une telle réforme
parce que je suis pas d'accord avec ce
avec ça au second tour en effet il y a
des gens qui ne sont pas partisans du
programme d'Emmanuel Macron et qui ont
voté pour Emmanuel Macron pour éviter
d'avoir très clairement mais juste pour
répondre sur ce point c'est pas vrai
premier tour et c'est pas vrai
législatif moi j'en ai parlé pendant ma
campagne et c'est le cas de beaucoup de
mes collègues de la majorité
relative certes mais on verra on verra à
la fin voilà la majorité absolue donc il
va falloir la construire une discussion
notamment avec avec les collègues verts
comme d'ailleurs avec les collègues du
PS qui ont voté il y a des carrières
longues je crois que les Français qui
nous regardent ont bien compris que
autour de 20 ans on cotise 44 ans alors
qu'après ces 43 est-ce que c'est
possible de changer cette règle là il
faut qu'on regarde ce point parce que à
la fin le seul objectif qu'on sait jouer
moi je souhaite qu'on regarde tous les
cas parce qu'il faut qu'on regarde
effectivement ça dépend d'abord si on a
continué à l'agir qu'à l'Archos ça
génération aussi exactement il y a
beaucoup de monde des républicains très
clairement il faut qu'on regarde dans la
dans le détail le sujet c'est la seule
le seul objectif qu'on s'est fixé c'est
de tenir l'équilibre des comptes en 2027
et 2000 et 2030 vous savez que non
seulement le corps pré prédit une un
déficit de 12 milliards d'euros qui est
prévu en 2027 et en 2030 d'une part et
d'autre part que l'État compense en
particulier les régimes sociaux à
hauteur de cette manière 5 tous les ans
de son budget donc donc si vous voulez
on parle pas d'une petite somme on parle
d'un quart des dépenses publiques qui
sont en plus très inertiels et donc
l'objectif c'est qu'on tienne notre
modèle de dépense publique et donc qui
demande cette ajuste Daniel il y a en
gros 10 à 30 milliards d'euros à trouver
à sauver à l'horizon 2030 est-ce que on
peut dire en tant qu'economiste vous
connaissez le sujet que au fond les
marges de manœuvre elle existe pas si on
lâche par exemple sur les carrières
longues c'est 2 milliards c'est ce qu'on
entend comme chiffres c'est trop oui
c'est dire qu'il y a tout un débat sur
la survie du système sur le niveau du
déficit encore une fois j'insiste sur
une chose c'est que quand l'État
providence a été créé à la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale il était
financé par des cotisations avec l'idée
d'ailleurs on parlait d'assurance il y
avait une logique qui était en cotisée
on était assuré à l'heure actuelle
l'état profitant ce n'est plus financé
qu'à la hauteur de la moitié par des
cotisations le reste c'est des impôts
des subventions de l'État et donc la
façon dont les tuyaux sont orientés la
Cour des comptes dans son rapport sur la
gestion de la sécurité sociale dit que
tous les ans il y a 40 impôts qui sont
affectés à la sécurité sociale et que
tous les ans leur orientation change
tantôt ça va vers la vieillesse tantôt
ça va vers la maladie tantôt ça va vers
la politique familiale si vous regardez
effectivement les comptes même de la
retraite vous apercevez que par exemple
les subventions de l'État c'est les
régimes spéciaux c'est aussi la
subvention que verse l'État pour assurer
le régime de retraite de ces agents
si les agents en question étaient au
régime général il y aurait un déficit
qui serait de l'ordre de 25 à 30
milliards d'euros comme l'état qu'on
pense qui déficit n'apparaît pas donc je
crois que l'enjeu c'est pas le déficit
tel qu'on le présente et sur lequel on
se bat je crois que l'enjeu c'est le
fait que encore une fois je vais
reprendre une citation qui est une
citation de quelqu'un qui est Maurice
Torres qui disait avant de revendiquer
il faut commencer par produire et donc
produire d'abord revendiquer ensuite le
problème du pays c'est qu'il le produit
pas assez et donc le but de la réforme
c'est d'augmenter le nombre de gens qui
travaillent pour produire davantage
c'est-à-dire que si on si on reporte
l'âge de départ à la retraite il y aura
plus d'actifs et moins de retraités et
là où le gouvernement est assez
maladroit je trouve c'est de ne pas dire
écoutez à l'heure actuelle en 1950 il y
avait quatre actifs pour un retrait
quand même oui mais il n'insiste pas
là-dessus c'est ça le vieux
on peut pas partager le gâteau tant
qu'on n'a pas augmenté la part la
dimension du gâteau la question de la
production du travail pour pouvoir
partager le gâteau ça c'est quelque
chose extrêmement simple à comprendre
vous pouvez pas être insensible à cette
question là
pas de problème mais en l'occurrence la
production en France elle augmente la
productivité des salariés elle augmente
en 50 ans ça a triplée
juste là-dessus la productivité n'est
plus au rendez-vous c'est ça le problème
mais vous avez raison depuis que Manuel
Macron est là effectivement ça a cassé
la tendance mais plus longtemps et
historiquement la productivité elle a
augmenté le gâteau il a augmenté le
produit intérieur brut le revenu il
augmente tout le monde se rend bien
compte au quotidien que il y a des
parties de ce pays qui déborde de
richesse qui a des versements qui sont
déclarés en dividende ou en différents
types de revenus d'ailleurs qui ne sont
pas soumis à cotisations qui sont
gigantesques que certains voient leurs
revenus progresser fortement à mon avis
beaucoup trop fortement tandis que
d'autres et bien tirent la langue et ont
des difficultés même à aller manifester
on le voyait là dans le documentaire
après sur le projet en tant que tel il
me semble que le grand public a compris
trois choses les plus pauvres vont payer
les femmes vont payer et les gens une
carrière longue vont payer c'est-à-dire
les personnes qui ont le plus de
difficultés à tenir au travail jusqu'à
61 tout le monde va cotiser un peu plus
tout le monde prend deux enfermes mais
deux enfers c'est pas la même chose
lorsque vous bossez dans un bureau que
lorsque vous travaillez par exemple en
ponçant des objets à bout de bras ou
dans une chambre froide etc donc les
gens qui ont démarré les carrières
longues ça ça permet quand même de
prendre en compte la spécificité des
métiers ça vous n'y croyez pas du tout
ça serait formidable mais ce n'est pas
le cas vous l'avez dit vous-même plus on
démarre jeune plus on devra faire de la
nuité dans le cadre de ce projet de loi
donc il y a une double peine non
seulement vous avez certains publics qui
n'ont pas fait d'études et qui auront
des salaires d'embauche
où elles seront obligés de travailler
plus longtemps dès lors se pose la
question centrale c'est où trouve-t-on
les 12 milliards d'euros parce que c'est
ça l'enjeu si on estime qu'il faut
effectivement mettre 12 milliards
d'euros de ressources dans les caisses
de retraite où trouve-t-on 12 milliards
d'euros et je crois bien sûr bien sûr
par an et je remarque que les
macronistes n'ont pas la main qui
tremble généralement pour faire des
cadeaux fiscaux 10 milliards d'euros par
an ça fait sept ans on a droit à décaler
l'ISF on peut prendre les zit tax on
peut prendre surtout parce que en
dépense récurrente pour des sociétés on
peut prendre surtout les cadeaux aux
grandes entreprises sans aucune espèce
de contrepartie je pense aussi ice je
pense à différentes formes d'exonération
de cotisation sociale 70 milliards
d'euros cette année là apparemment
l'argent magique existe en revanche pour
nos retraites cet argent devient
absolument impossible et on a un
ministre monsieur dupe qui nous explique
qu'en gros c'est lui ou le chaos et que
si on trouve si on n'arrive pas à
réformer dans les deux mois on va avoir
des pistes le programme de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon sur la question des plus
riches et des dividendes fabiennes têtes
au vous qui êtes syndicaliste il y a un
débat à l'Assemblée nationale et il a
commencé en commission il va prendre
leur lait dans l'hémicycle à partir du 6
à l'Assemblée ça va durer trois semaines
aux alentours de début mars sera terminé
est-ce que vous considérez vous que si
la réforme est votée il va falloir
l'accepter cette réforme alors il est
pas question d'accepter cette réforme
même si elle si elle est votée par les
représentants on acceptera pas la
mobilisation montre que l'opinion
publique elle est pas du tout pour
accepter que la rue est plus forte que
l'assemblée je pense que c'est une
évidence qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement
a perdu une forme de légitimité parce
qu'il sentait et aujourd'hui il joue les
gros bras en disant qu'il ne voudra rien
modifier à son projet de réforme alors
même qu'on en a encore au stade des
discussions sur les amendements voilà
donc ils sont en bourbe dans une
retraite ferme voilà ou rien et il
n'écoute pas la mobilisation de la rue
qui a très bien compris ce qu'il attend
moi je voudrais quand même donner un ou
deux exemples concernant les femmes
parce qu'on en parle depuis le début de
l'émission alors sur les femmes
soi-disant que c'était au départ une
réforme qui allait dans le sens d'un
progrès pour les femmes alors sur les
carrières incomplètes 19% des femmes
contre 10% des hommes attendent 67 ans
pour partir en retraite et la moitié des
femmes contre un tiers des hommes
perçoivent le min de pension on a 37% de
femmes retraitées et 15% d'hommes qui
touchent moins de 1000 euros brut de
pension c'est leur pratique alors pour
terminer ce débat la retraite le votre
projet de la fin sensiblement la
situation des femmes et il y a pas que
les femmes je suis quand même dire que
les jeunes diplômés eux aussi vont
passer à la casserole et que on en parle
jamais mais sur les cadres eux avec le
régime agir Arrco c'est pas deux ans qui
prennent ces trois ans faut pas voir on
va rester sur les femmes pour terminer
est-ce que ça c'est une question on
entend beaucoup parler de gouvernement
en coulisses des droits familiaux est-ce
que ça ça peut évoluer peut-être même
sur un autre texte de loi un texte
emploi dans le sur lesquels le travail
des femmes serait amélioré non mais
évidemment mais ça c'est un point très
important on a tout entendu sur le sur
le sur le comme si on n'était pas
sensible comme si vous étiez les seuls
elles sont sensibles
et bien c'est faux et bien il se trouve
que quand on regarde quand on regarde
les courbes les femmes vont partir à la
retraite
dans une dizaine de minutes les parties
pris de nos affranchis ce soir Yanis
roder nous parle de la dilkra cette
instance gouvernementale de lutte contre
le racisme ou le conseil scientifique à
brutalement été dissout Vincent Huger
revient sur la situation en Israël qui
s'enfonce dans la violence et puis
Bourbon Express bien sûr avec Elsa
Montana l'histoire du jour règlement à
la main allez on va parler à présent de
votre riz livre un manifeste pour les
arts de la parole ça mérite explication
vous l'homme de théâtre Gérald guerotti
vous nous invitez à renouer avec
l'altérité avec la complexité et avec la
nuance car il faut voir comme on nous
parle aujourd'hui regardez c'est dans
l'invitation de m'a été vraiment
si on vous invite Gérald garrupti c'est
pour nous parler d'un mal de notre
société
du clash et de la punchline la vérité
à l'heure où chacun s'exprime se lâche
et se tacle tu vas la ferme il faut voir
comment se parle titre de votre dernière
ouvrage voici votre manifeste pour les
arts de la parole
134 pages où vous l'artisan du verbe en
action et ouvriers du lien humain vous
alerter sur une parole dégradée la
parole dites-vous exige l'écoute et
demande du temps et dans une dictature
de l'immédiat dans un monde de plus en
plus virtuel il vous semblait important
de rappeler que proclamer n'est pas
parlé et qu'être connecté n'est pas être
relié
on assiste à une fin de la possibilité
même du débat et du dialogue et de
l'échange le fameux citation de Voltaire
je ne suis pas d'accord avec vous mais
je me battrai pour que vous puissiez
défendre vos idées c'est ça s'appelle le
débat ça s'appelle le dialogue et non
pas l'annulation de l'autre
géraldaruti bien difficile de vous
résumer en quelques phrases vous êtes
metteur en scène dramaturge écrivain et
traducteur vous vous décrivez comme un
passeur de texte il faut dire que le
théâtre et l'écriture vous animent vous
mettre en la matière Michel Bouquet ou
encore Yann McKellen et vous en avez
adapté des pièces de théâtre à votre
actif 45 spectacles de Shakespeare à
Romain Gary en passant par Dostoïevski
le tout en dirigeant de nombreux acteurs
comme Mathieu Kassovitz Pierre Richard
ou encore Paul Anderson ni votre Carte
d'Identité ne serait pas complète sans
parler de votre envie de transmettre
votre savoir normalien agrégé diplômée
de Cambridge et de Sciences Po vous
enseignez vous êtes aussi docteur en
littérature comparé et philosophie vous
êtes ce que l'on appelle un passeur de
Savoie une transmission qui passe par la
théorie mais aussi par la pratique vous
vous apprêtez à inaugurer et un centre
des arts de la parole à Aubervilliers
alors une question ce soir Gérald de
gareuti n’êtes-vous pas un peu utopiste
à croire que l'on peut retisser les
liens de cette parole si abîmée en
partant du terrain
réponse
Gérald Haïti je pense que nous avons
besoin d'utopie je pense nous avons
besoin d'horizon je pense que l'un des
problèmes que nous avons c'est ce manque
de perspective à la fois un manque de
mémoire et on est condamné à revivre
l'histoire quand on ne s'en souvient pas
on envoie des exemples assez atroces et
puis quand on a pas d'horizon on a le
nez bouché la vue collé sur la vitre et
on ne peut pas on ne peut pas aller de
l'avant alors on va parler du Cap ce
centre des arts de la parole dans le
détail mais avant quand même un mot sur
le diagnostic comment on en est arrivé
là à ce niveau de dégradation à la fois
de la parole
de lui une forme de négation de l'autre
et du débat je pense que c'est un
processus qui vient de loin avec le mal
vient de plus loin que les réseaux
sociaux je pense que c'est une tendance
de fond je pense que c'est lié à
l'accélération du temps c'est à dire
qu'il s'agit de plus en plus de réagir
de rebondir et la parole prend du temps
demande de l'élaboration de la nuance
demande de pouvoir échanger et on est de
plus en plus dans une aire de l'immédiat
et dans une société d'émission et pour
moi la société d'émissions c'est la
démission de la société ça veut dire que
émettre envoyé balancer tout le temps
sans prendre le temps de recevoir
d'échanger d'écouter sans prendre le
temps du silence
là ce que je fais normalement c'est
impossible à la télévision mais vous
voyez je ne vous ai pas interrompu parce
que vous écoutez mais là la capacité de
faire du silence pour que la parole et
de la résonance et qu'on puisse
véritablement dialoguer je pense que
c'est une condition pour se retrouver se
retrouver soit parce que on se perd avec
les défilements et les instants
où on est condamné à l'entre-soi ou on
va chercher soi-même à travers un
semblant une fiction d'altérité oui oui
et en effet de repli de repli avec des
miroirs aux alouettes qui sont des
écrans où on se regarde soi-même on se
contente comme des narcisses et on est
dans des communautés qui finissent par
tronder en boucle littéralement tourner
en rond et donc avec une incapacité à
rencontrer l'autre et l'autre c'est la
différence c'est la capacité à ne pas
être d'accord effectivement et de plus
en plus on ne peut plus tolérer
quelqu'un qui n'est pas comme soi du
même avis que soi et même on lui retire
le droit la possibilité d'exister tu
n'as pas le droit de tester les dérives
de l'usage de la parole les mots tuent
vraiment vous avez des phrases vous
dites au fond les nomciation dégénère de
façon écrasante en dénonciation en
ségrégation en destruction à ce point-là
regardez les suicides d'adolescents liés
au harcèlement sur les réseaux sociaux
regardez les pilonnages et que quelqu'un
ose dire un mot de travers regardez
l'analy qui peut arriver très très vite
et des vies qui peuvent être brisés les
exemples sont légion je vois bien sûr le
côté positif les réseaux sociaux nous
ont permis ou Internet de d'abord d'être
encore en contact par exemple durant le
grand confinement le grand retranchement
mais n'empêche où est-ce qu'on peut
encore vraiment se parler s'écouter
alors on est en 2019 il y a 5 ans
à Londres
vous vous êtes en train de monter une
pièce importante Tartuffe en anglais et
en français et là débarque Donald Trump
avec son lot de fracassant tweet
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans votre tête
alors effectivement je suis à Londres en
train de mettre en scène à Tartuffe et
la particularité c'est que c'est la
première pièce bilingue donc en français
et en anglais donc la langue de Molière
au royaume de Shakespeare et ces deux
langues ensemble au Théâtre royal en
plein brexit donc faire une pièce
bilingue en plein dans plein brexit
c'est un peu de la provocation c'est
volontaire et effectivement alors que
moi j'essaie de faire en sorte que ça se
parle et non pas que ça s'écarte et
j'essaie de construire des ponts quand
d'autres font des murs et bien il y a
cette venue de Trump qui comme il le dit
d'ailleurs une vérité chasse l'autre et
les fait alternatives et les
contre-vérités et c'est pour moi un
point de cristallisation sur cette
dégradation radicale de la parole je
pense que tenir parole fait que par
exemple il y a une façon de d'avoir une
cohérence dans le temps une chose qui
est dite après à du sens plus tard a été
de plus en plus balayé c'est-à-dire que
juste dans la parole de l'instant et
donc à ce moment-là je me dis mais il y
a qu'un problème grave de civilisation
et c'est de ce noyau là que je me dis il
y a un sens à mon avis fondamental à
porter une parole qui soit une parole de
dépassement on pense à les vinasse quand
on lit parce que dans le visage de
l'autre la reconnaissance de l'autre la
capacité à écouter l'autre pour se
définir au fond soi-même pour savoir qui
l'on est c'est c'est frappant pour vous
la parole c'est bien autre chose qu'un
simple moyen de communication c'est
fondateurs soi-même alors je suis très
touché que vous parlez de l'évidence qui
est préférence importante pour moi qui
effectivement dit que le visage de
l'autre et ce qui me convoque et ce qui
m'oblige et je pense que la parole est
d'abord un art de l'autre on pense
aujourd'hui que la parole c'est le souci
de soi c'est l'expression de son
intériorité très bien laboratoire
l'efficacité je pense que la parole est
un art du lien que c'est une manière de
se relier de rencontrer après l'autre
effectivement et que il s'agit pas
simplement d'avoir une parole qui
impacte c'est une conception balistique
de la parole la parole comme performance
que méloquence qui va juste taper juste
taper dans l'autre je pense que la
parole est un fait humain totale c'est
une manière d'exister dans toutes nos
dimensions humaines et donc
effectivement cette on existe aussi
parce qu'on est avec et pour les autres
c'est ça les arts de la parole parce que
la parole c'est l'art de l'autre et les
arts de la parole à quoi
correspondent-ils ce que vous les
défendre et bien justement ça n'est pas
seulement l'art de la parole l'art de la
parole c'est l'éloquence c'est le fait
de savoir bien parler et il y a une bien
sûr une noblesse de l'éloquence sauf
qu'aujourd'hui on confond les vacances
avec la performance et la performance
avec cette notion d'outils de parole
ensuite la création la poésie la
transmission aussi il y a cet art de la
parole le théâtre le récit la poésie qui
sont des arts de création une parole qui
se formulent qui s'adresse qui se
racontent des arts de position avec
l'éloquence et puis la conférence donnée
du sens et puis des arts très important
parce qu'on en a un peu parlé juste
avant qui sont des arts de l'interaction
le débat et le dialogue et je pense que
on a tendance à confondre le dialogue
avec le débat et le débat avec la
destruction de l'autre or dire que le
dialogue les débats doivent être des
arts pour moi c'est tout revalorisé
alors on entend le diagnostic les mots
que vous posez sur ce qui nous arrive la
pratique le cap
Centre des arts de la parole qui vont va
faire son premier événement à
Aubervilliers en mars prochain qui quoi
comment ça va se passer alors qui
qui d'abord
moi je consomme dans cette aventure 30
ans de vie de création de transmission
de réflexion mais ça dépasse largement
ma personne l'enjeu c'est de créer une
fédération au-delà d'un lieu le cap est
un mouvement c'est-à-dire une dynamique
collective qui a vocation à fédérer des
énergies des collectifs des
organisations avec une parole qui permet
de se dépasser de se relier alors j'ai
vu la philosophe Cynthia Fleury j'en
cite quelques-uns simplement la
romancière Eliette à bécassis le
violoniste Carole Beffa le chanteur
Arthur c'est dû au niveau ça quand même
il y a aussi je précise le rapport
fianso qui voulez-vous réunir est-ce que
ils viennent à vous aussi c'est vous qui
allez les chercher là vous citer des
membres du Conseil du cap qui est une
instance qui regroupe des artistes de la
parole donc évidemment que ce sont des
personnes qui incarnent des dimensions
de la parole la poésie vous l'avez cité
il y a quoi Mtawa il y a akimba au 1040
traditions de parole de compte par
exemple et en effet fianso le rappeur
donc a vraiment une ouverture sur des
arts de la parole qui ne sont pas que le
théâtre le récit et qui sont des arts de
la parole qui peuvent à mon sens toucher
tout le monde pourquoi parce que je
pense que si chacun développe la parole
comme une somme d'art et bien c'est une
manière
je dirais de se constituer de se
construire et de se relier alors ça
c'est le premier cercle premier cercle
c'est ce conseil du cap et l'équipe avec
laquelle je travaille et puis il y a un
deuxième cercle qui sont des partenaires
je pense à la Cité Internationale de
langue française le Samu Social le
Centre national du livre donc qui sont
des institutions qui sont engagées avec
nous dans des actions très concrètes et
dans une démarche une philosophie je
dirais la même comment la parole nous
relie nos élèves et puis il y a un
troisième cercle et là c'est une forme
d'appel effectivement c'est à dire
quiconque que ce soit des organisations
des citoyens des citoyennes des
personnes publiques privées qui a envie
de rejoindre cette démarche et bien est
amené à participer et ça va se passer à
Aubervilliers pour ce premier événement
c'est un mouvement ça n'est pas qu'un
espace où vous vivez d'ailleurs
Aubervilliers dernière question pour en
parler très longtemps mais comment vous
embarquez tout le monde comment faire en
sorte que ça ne soit pas un mouvement un
peu élitiste alors on a un ancrage à
Aubervilliers en Seine-Saint-Denis avec
un lien très fort avec le territoire
mais c'est un mouvement je dirais qui
est nomade qui rayonne sur tous les
territoires y compris d'ailleurs sur
Internet on a des créations spectacles
festivals qui vont être itinérants on a
des publications on a une chaîne de
podcast qu'on va lancer pour parler et
puis on a des formations parce que il
est fondamental de former dans le temps
long à la parole aux arts de la parole
et on était tout à l'heure justement
réunion avec un partenaire ou pour
différents territoires l'objectif n'est
pas d'être enclavé c'est au contraire de
relier de désenclaver et de faire se
croiser des mondes et se parler des mots
c'est un mouvement à la fois on a
compris éthique et citoyen et politique
dans le sens noble du terme merci
beaucoup Gérald garretti vous restez
avec moi il faut voir comment on se
parle c'est le manifeste et puis on va
peut-être vous suivre avec une caméra
sur sur le terrain pour voir pour voir
ce que ça donne un peu le dans les pas
de gens Vilar j'ai envie de dire le
théâtre populaire allez on passe au
parti pris de nos affranchis vous allez
voir ils vont vous faire réagir on les
accueille tout de suite
bonsoir les affranchis
Yanis Robert une nouvelle histoire
d'école qui nous parle de la dilkra
cette fois-ci c'est un peu différent
cette délégation interministérielle de
lutte contre le racisme qui a dissout ça
a même fait l'objet d'une question au
gouvernement son conseil scientifique on
y revient dans un instant et Vincent
bonsoir Vincent
en Israël ce qui s'enfonce ce pays de
plus en plus dans la violence on
commence comme chaque soir par boubou
Express l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
nous est racontée par Elsa mondain Elsa
bataille référendaires oui je vais vous
raconter l'histoire d'un tirage au sort
d'un tirage au sort qui passe très très
mal au sein de la nuque je vous en
parlais déjà la semaine dernière avec 98
députés le groupe communiste a déposé
une motion référendaire ça permet et
bien de demander un référendum sur un
texte précis ici la réforme des
retraites en déposant leurs motion en
premier les communistes pensaient la
faire acter mais le rassemblement
national a décidé d'en déposer d'en
déposer une 24 heures plus tard à
l'Assemblée on s'affole la situation est
inédite alors que dit le règlement de
l'Assemblée alors le règlement en ce
moment on dort avec Myriam il dit dans
son article 22 il ne peut être présenté
qu'une seule motion tendance à proposer
de soumettre ce projet à référendum
présenter c'est un peu imprécis ça veut
pas dire déposer ça veut pas dire
discuter donc en conférence de président
ce matin où on réunit les présidents des
groupes les présidents des commissions
on essaye de se mettre d'accord les
communistes disent on la déposé en
premier elle est signée par plus de
députés on doit donc discuter la nôtre
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
elle décide de proposer un tirage au
sort comme c'est le cas par exemple pour
les motion de rejet et là c'est la
motion référendaire du RN du
rassemblement national qui est tiré au
sort la nuque est furieuse les
communistes étaient sûrs de leur coûts
ils avaient vraiment pris de vitesse le
rassemblement national ils ont
l'impression de s'être fait doubler sur
la ligne d'arrivée et ils n'ont pas du
tout la même interprétation du règlement
que la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale
c'est l'article 122 du règlement il
précise que de ne pas être présenté
qu'une seule motion là il y en avait
deux c'était un peu inédit comment ça
s'est passé ça s'est passé que j'ai
démontré à quel point la lecture du
règlement notamment de la table
analytique des matières était très
claire qu'il y avait seulement une seule
motion qui pouvait déposer
ça pas été suivi il y a une
interprétation faite par la présidente
de l'Assemblée faisant en sorte qu'on
accepter
deux motions déposées et qu'ensuite on
ne tenait pas compte du fait qu'il y en
avait une qui avait été déposée en
premier avec un plus grand nombre de
signataires et la présidente de
l'Assemblée a proposé un tirage au sort
et ce tirage au sort nous n'étions pas
d'accord avec cette méthode là et au
final au final il a fait en sorte sur le
rassemblement national qui porte cette
motion voilà on l'a entendu André
Chassagne il est député depuis 20 ans il
connaît le règlement il connaît les
tables analytiques du règlement mais
l'assemblée bien n'est pas d'accord il
s'appuie sur le fait qu'il y a pas
vraiment de jurisprudence et c'est une
réponse qu'on nous fait souvent en ce
moment tout est neuf tout est on
découvre des alinéas de règlement et
puis Marine Le Pen elle bah celle des
quatre colonnes elle jubilait
les groupes nuls sont toujours foudrages
si vous voulez quel que soit les
circonstances c'est un état naturel pour
eux d'être en permanence en colère et
plein de haine et ils peuvent
s'agacer contre la chance peut-être mais
contre personne d'autre
non alors qu'est-ce qui va se passer
comment faire des groupes de gauche
alors pour l'instant il comptait la
décision ils ont envoyé un courrier à la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale il
demande à ce qu'on enlève ce tirage au
sort donc ils ne veulent pas vraiment se
prononcer mais en fait elle est là à la
question c'est que pour la gauche la
majorité c'est très bien que certains
groupes ne voteront pas une motion si
elle vient du rassemblement national et
donc elle a encore moins de chance
d'être adopté écouter la socialiste
Christine Perez bonne est-ce que vous
pensez que la majorité craignait plus
votre motion référendaire de la gauche
que celle du rassemblement national oui
elle le craint plus tout simplement
parce qu'elle sait que la digue
républicaine elle tient toujours chez
nous voilà et donc en les sensations
sont rassemblement national elle s'est
pertinemment que des parties comme le
Parti socialiste ne voteront jamais
cette motion référendaire les
socialistes les écolos ne la voteront
pas c'est encore en discussion chez les
insoumis et chez les communistes mais
comme on se le disait Myriam de toute
façon qu'elles viennent de la gauche ou
du RN il y avait peu de chances qu'elle
soit à adoptée
il faut se souvenir que François Bayrou
voulait un référendum sur les retraites
donc ouais même dans la majorité cette
option a été un tout petit peu défendu
merci beaucoup Elsa alors Yanis on
enchaîne avec vous il y a eu ce plan de
lutte contre le racine qui a été
proposée donc par cette institution qui
s'appelle la dilkra qui dépend de
Matignon et il y a même eu aujourd'hui
une question au gouvernement sur le
sujet et vous voulez revenir dessus oui
alors la discret c'est en effet doté
d'un conseil scientifique en 2016
composé d'universitaire et d'experts
chargé de porter des réflexions de des
analyses et d'expertiser les initiatives
voilà et aujourd'hui ce conseil n'existe
plus et c'est la question qui a posé cet
après-midi lors des questions au
Gouvernement la députée Astrid Panossian
Bouvet pourquoi voilà à la Ministre
chargé d'égalité Isabelle Rome et voici
ce que celle-ci a répondu sur la
question de la dissolution du conseil
scientifique que vous évoquez il ne
reposait sur aucun cas juridique n'était
encadré ni dans sa composition ni dans
ses missions force est de constater
qu'il ne produisait plus grand chose
depuis plusieurs mois les intéressés
apprécieront alors la visiblement un
petit peu beauté en touche la ministre
qu'elles se sont pas les raisons
qu'avant cela presse nous en effet
Myriam on a eu pas mal d'articles la
semaine dernière qui nous ont informé
que ce conseil scientifique d'abord a
été 18 sans explication aucune fournit
au membre mais aussi qu'il ne s'agit pas
uniquement de questions de forme comme
le dit la ministre c'est ce que exprime
aussi dans sa question la députée
Panneuse en pouvait je résume
une fracture est apparue en 2022 au sein
du conseil scientifique présidé par le
sociologue Smaïn lacher il a été
reproché à ce dernier par quelques
membres du conseil scientifique parmi
lesquels des spécialistes des questions
de genre et de transidentité de faire
partie du conseil administration d'une
association l'Observatoire de la petite
sirène dirigée par la pédopsychiatre
Caroline eliachesse à l'universitaire et
psychanalyste Céline Masson cette
observatoire c'est donner pour mission
de protéger les mineurs qui connaissent
une dysphorie de genre c'est à dire qui
pense que leur genre ne correspond pas à
leur sexe biologique jusqu'à vouloir
passer par la chirurgie pour leur pour
faire concorder sexe et genre et
l'achève et maçon cherchent ainsi à
prévenir chez les mineurs l'utilisation
de bloqueurs de puberté et des
opérations chirurgicales irréversées
a donc jugé plus prudent de démissionner
du conseil d'administration de ces
associations pour calmer les autres
protestations apparues au sein du
conseil scientifique et donc pourquoi le
gouvernement a choisi dissoudre ce
conseil scientifique une question Myriam
en choisissant la dissolution le
gouvernement acte en démocratie
l'impossibilité de dialogue entre des
intellectuels au-delà du fait que le
gouvernement choisi de se séparer d'un
outil de réflexion et d'un lien avec le
monde universitaire c'est le choix
politique qui préside à cette absence
d'arbitrage en fait entre une vision
universaliste et une vision disons le
franchement plus particulariste et
militante qui me semble-t-il à entraîner
la question de la députée Astrid
panosiane Bouvet je ne suis pas certain
que la réponse de la ministre Rome
laisse satisfaite
et voilà un parti pris signé il y a des
frauder allez on enchaîné le temps nous
est compté Vincent ce soir vous vouliez
vous y revenir sur la situation en
Israël commençons par une confidence
après avoir longtemps couvert pour
L'Express la brio Israël au palestinien
je l'ai choisi voilà une quinzaine
d'années de céder le flambeau pour une
raison simple au fil de mes reportages
j'avais la détestable impression
d'écrire toujours le même papier à
regarder 9 s'imposer à ceci près que
d'autres yeux voient autrement une même
réalité accablante et mortifère voici
cette terre que l'on dit trois fois
sainte trop sainte pour n'être pas
maudite endeuillez une fois encore par
une effroyable éruption de violence
jeudi dernier Red Dead l'armée d'Israël
sur Jenny bastion islamiste en 6
Jordanie occupé dit tu es 15 blessés le
lendemain aux abords d'une synagogue de
navaya COV un palestinien dont le
grand-père fut assassiné jadis par un
colon israélien rafale les passants à
l'aveugle cette mort si israéliens une
Ukrainienne depuis un an tous les
voyants sont au rouge sans l'exercice
écoulé aura le plus meurtrier depuis la
fin de la deuxième Intifada en 2005 235
morts au 4/5 palestinien ajoutons-y les
39 cadavres recensés depuis le début de
ce mois alors comment réagit à la
communauté internationale face à cette
embrasement
d'indifférence et de fatalisme les mêmes
constats navré face à la spirale
l'engrenage l'impasse faites votre choix
les mêmes objets aussi Vennes que
rituels venus de Washington Moscou ou
Paris ces appels pressants à la retenue
maximale ici à la désescalade là on
imagine mal Emmanuel Macron qui reçoit
jeudi le Premier ministre israélien
Netanyahou puisé dans un autre registre
soyons clairs l'entrée en scène du
cabinet le plus droitier de l'histoire
d'Israël orchestrée par un bibi prête au
pire pour remonter sur le trône et donc
échappé à la justice de son pays
n'explique pas tout le mal est plus
ancien est plus profond il date du
sabordage de la formule à deux états
désormais chimérique de jeunes arabes
qui n'ont d'autres horizons que l'EN et
l'occupation ce radicalise quitte à ce
mur en nous solitaire réfractaire aux
consignes de l'Autorité palestinienne
amplement discréditée et qu'au président
Mahmoud Abbas que la nouvelle donne
politique le nouveau gouvernement de
coalition de Benyamin Netanya pas les
choses certes pas l'accession à la tête
de ministère clé de suprématistes juives
de boots racistes de sionistes
religieuses exelté adeptes de l'annexion
touzazimuth et repris de justice pour
certains d'entre eux d'ailleurs
alimentent le brasier allusion à Itamar
bengwir titulaire du portefeuille de la
sécurité nationale donc patron de la
police ou à betzalal smotrich chargée au
sein du ministère de la Défense
d'administrer ce que Netanyahou et son
orchestre persiste à désigner sous le
nom de Judée Samari cette fine équipe
n'a pas tardé à pardon on a pas tardé à
bénir les avant-postes illégaux tenus
par les colons les plus belliqueux de si
j'en ai mis elle se fait fort de
faciliter le port d'armes et de durcir
les châtiments collectifs infligés aux
proches des auteurs d'attentats on
pourra sous peu raser logement sans
préavis ni procédure d'appel voir
supprimer tout droit aux prestations
sociales et s'agissant des résidents de
Jérusalem Est de révoquer leur statut
message reçu cinq sur cinq par les
allumés de la Torah qui au hasard de
descente punity caillas ou incendie
voiture maison et commerce il y a de
part et d'autre on leur a compris de la
fuite en avant dans l'air un air saturé
de haine et de ressentiment vous qui
entrez sur ce champ de mine abandonné
tout espérance merci elle est
désespérante cette situation vous
arrivez encore à vous intéresser à ce
conflit sans fin vous détournez un peu
le regard faute d'espoir
des violences du monde en général
surtout quand le monde de tape à votre
porte
et que tout se radicalise et tout se
voit partout mais je voudrais revenir
sur une chose que vous avez dites sur la
disparition ou la suppression d'espaces
possibles de dialogue entre des avis
opposés pour moi c'est une des clés
c'est à dire que l'absence par exemple
de véritables débats que nous avons eu
durant la présidentielle avec une sorte
de confiscation et de climat de terreur
et d'incapacité véritablement d'échanger
des positions j'entends constituer la
capacité d'avoir des espaces où on peut
dialoguer avec des différences entre
connaissances je pense et un des
problèmes qui fait que il y a cette
radicalisation et ses effets de la crise
démocratique merci on pourrait continuer
longtemps c'est fini merci beaucoup
Gérald garretti et merci à vous les
affranchis il faut voir comment on se
parle le Manifeste des arts de la parole
c'est-à-dire chez Acte Sud à demain si
vous le voulez bien
[Musique]